graphs of e of x equals e to the x and r
of x is equal to 1 over x times x minus
1 times x minus 2 are shown below
estimate the solution to e to the x so
that's e of x being equal to essentially
r of x within
0.01 so we want to figure out we want to
figure out for what value does e of x
equal r of x
equal
r of x and they want us to estimate it
we can either just try to get as close
as we can from this graph they want us
to be within 0.01
and we can also use a calculator to kind
of try numbers out to hopefully zero in
on this point right over here where e of
x is equal to
r of x so what i want to do is let me
draw a little table here
let's try out some x values and then for
each of these x values let's see where
we land on e of x
on e of x
and where we land on r of x
and where we land on r of x and then we
can decide whether we are too high or
too low and i encourage you to pause
this video before i actually go ahead
and do this and try to do this on your
own but i do suggest using some form of
calculator or or probably a calculator
i'm assuming you've given a go at it now
i will attempt it now just eyeballing it
and eyeballing it is helpful because
that will give us kind of our first
order approximation of what at what x
value are these two functions equal if
we look if i just look at this graph the
way it's drawn it looks like
this is pretty close
to 2.1
pretty close to
2.1 it looks like when x is 2.1 both of
those functions look pretty close to
i don't know this looks like about
7.7.7 or 7.8 or something like that but
let's let's figure out what they're
doing so let's see when x is equal to
2.1
and get my calculator out
when x is equal to 2.1
e of x
is is just well e of x is just e to the
x power
so
e
to the 2.1 power
is equal to
8.166 so let me write that down
8.166 and what is r of x r of x
is 1
divided by
x so that's going to be 2.1
times x minus 1. well that's going to be
1.1
so that's times 1.1
times x minus 2 well that's just going
to be 0.1 times 0.1
and that is equal to
4 did i do that right no that can't be
it's 2.1 it's 2.1 over 2.1 times 1 to
1.1
times 0.1 1 over all of that so did that
4.32
see 2.1 r of x is 4 point i guess that's
possible actually that looks right
because r of x declines so sharply right
over here so it's actually at 2.1 where
actually r of x is actually closer to
right over
right over here give or take so it's
equal to 4.32
so at 2.1 e of x is actually a much
larger value than r of x so e of x is
clearly e of x is clearly too high r of
x has already dropped a good bit by then
if i were to go all the way down to two
at two it looks like r of x it looks
like actually r of x kind of spikes up
it's a it's it just it just it just goes
to infinity as we approach two so we're
not going to go all the way down to two
but why don't we lower this a little bit
why don't we try 2.05
so 2.05
what is e of x e to the e of x is e to
the x right so e
to the
2.05 power
gets us
7.76 i'll round it eight 7.76
approximately
seven actually all of these are
approximate so i'll just write
7.768
and what is r of x i'll just keep
rounding to the thousandths here we
didn't even have to well we didn't have
to round too much just because that was
so far off but i'll put it there it was
three two actually
it was three to nine so i could
let me write it this way it's three two
nine zero so let me throw that nine here
just so everything we evaluate the
function to the thousandths so let's
evaluate r of x when we're at
2.05 it's going to be 1 divided by x
which is now 2.05
times x minus 1 which is 1.05
times x minus 2 which is
0.05
and that gets us to
9.29
around to 2. 9.292
so 9.292
so now we're on this side where r of x
is roughly right over here and it's more
than e of x which is at 7.7 which is
right around here so now we've our x
value is too low
so let's see maybe let's see if we can
go a little bit higher and we'll go
let's try to go roughly halfway between
these two
and but i don't want to get too precise
because we have to get to the nearest
hundredth so let's go to 2.07
2.07
so e to the 2.07
is equal to
7.925 if i round it
7.925 7.925
i want to do all of this in green
just to be color consistent and now
let's evaluate r of x at that same value
so 1 divided by x which is 2.07
times that minus 1 which is 1.07 times
that minus 2 which is
0.07
which gives us
6.44
i guess we could say 6.450
6.450
so at 2.05 that was too low 2.07 is too
high now r of x has dropped below e of x
so 2 point so we know the right answer
is in between these two numbers and so
if we select 2.06 that's definitely
going to be within
0.01 of the right answer so i would go
i would go with 2.2.06
is going is definitely going to be
within
0.01 of the correct solution to this but
just for fun let's actually just try it
out
so e
to the 2.06
is 7.84
i guess we could round to six and if we
were to evaluate r of x it's one divided
by
2.06 times that minus one which is 1.06
times
0.06
gets us
to
7.632 so we're also getting pretty
pretty close but our precision that they
gave they don't say that these have to
equal they have to be within each other
of that they say let's estimate the
solution so there's some
actual precise solution to this right
over here some x value where these are
actually equal to each other that's
that's the x value which gives us this
point of intersection we just have to
get within 0.01 of that x value and 2.06
definitely does the trick